So here in week one, I want to talk about a great starting subject of how to set your mindset on how to think about your horse and about what they're thinking of.
So when you go in to your riding or your groundwork session with an intention, it goes way better.
So I want you to listen to these, you know, preferably at the beginning and at the end of the week and give yourself almost like a little score.
Did I get better with the thing that I'm trying to work on this week, number one?
And also, did I come with an intention every time I worked my horse?
So this week, I want you to think of putting yourself in your horse's shoes.
So I want you to think of what they could be thinking, just like you would another person.
So sometimes how I like to start with people and with horses is like, how is your day going?
Can you ask your horse that question? Were they just turned out? Did they just come from a stall? What are the circumstances of their day? Did you just wake them up?
Did they just eat? Did they not eat yet? They're so hungry.
All of those things matter when we go to work with our horse.
So, you know, another thing to think of that I hear a lot of people not really mentioning or giving themselves or giving their horses credit for is how are they feeling physically?
Give your horse a chance to kind of answer that question and they answer in a couple ways.
They will answer when you palpate their body and they will give an answer like pinning their ears when you touch their shoulder or back or hip or wherever they're sore.
Or they'll be super happy and when you hug them, they're like, yes, Nagomi, they're having a pretty good day.
Those things matter.
And then, of course, how does your horse feel about this exercise?
That's the biggest thing. Get very specific.
So in this, you know, in this week, you're going to go and be like, okay, well, are they confused?
Are they sure? Do they feel safe? Are they distracted? Are they focused?
And why? And like, you know, what would the reason be that they are distracted or focused?
If they're very connected to you and they stay focused, even though there's chaos going around, then you can say, okay, well, we've just had a good connection.
But number one, you have to seek to understand before you can provide a solution or else your solution isn't going to be very good.
Right. Like if you don't ever listen to your friend and they're complaining about something that they're really struggling with and they want to they want your help or they want your advice.
You just don't listen. How good is your advice going to be?
So let that ring in your ears there. You want to listen and have good advice.
So when your horse has a response or a reaction, ask yourself, do I understand why they had this reaction?
Do I understand what the reaction was? Was the reaction to me? Was it the reaction to what they were thinking?
Is this like an issue that doesn't, you know, have to do with me?
Or were they reacting to their environment or something like this?
So if you can interact with horses, you can interact with people.
And if you can interact with people, you can interact with horses.
And so ask yourself these questions before you provide a solution.
Lots of times people just want to jump on like, well, just stand still.
Well, what if he's reacting to something that requires him to not stand still like a bug?
Right. Well, why don't you just why don't you just listen?
Well, he doesn't know what he's listening for and why it's important to be listening to you.
What is the point of this? Right.
And so I want you to put yourself in your horse's shoes.
I want you to write down every time, you know, you think you've got something new from your horse, like, oh, like I saw a different reaction.
And I'm not even sure what the solution is, but my observing was better.
So that's what I want you to bring to your call this week.
For the sake of the horse, let's get better.